i think let's get started so today
we're in the beyond satisfiability
seminar series
um and
perhaps one of the smallest steps beyond
sat is to take a satisfiability a sat
formula plus an objective for instance
you know satisfying as much of the
formula as possible this is known as
maximum satisfiability solving or max
that solving
it's a rich paradigm that captures many
problems that we know and love
and we are fortunate today to have
yeremias
berg and matti jarvisallo from the
university of helsinki
who are behind some of the so i should
say max at solving
i think it's fair to say that this is a
dynamically developing area lots and
lots of
exciting news cool algorithmic
techniques in the last
few years decade or so maybe uh pretty
amazing
performance of the best solvers i'm sure
uh yeremias and mati will tell us about
it
and they're very well placed to do so
since they are behind some of these
cutting edge techniques and the cutting
edge solvers so
with that without further ado uh mate
and jeremias the
floor is all yours and thanks very much
and thanks for the invitation you can
hear me right
um so yeah we we're splitting this
sort of switching between me and
jeremy's
and uh i think there's a place for a
break there
after eremis's first turn but i'll start
with an intro now
so so the story behind this is that this
is sort of a revised and truncated
version of an
earlier tutorial on maksha that we gave
at ekko
last year uh and this that then build on
on a tutorial that we gave with fahim ah
yeah yeah
last year with ruben rubin unfortunately
couldn't
make it today because of his personal
schedules got really really bad
um and yeah and and and that tutorial
was based on an earlier
tutorial that we gave with fahim at
triple ai some years ago
but hopefully this is slightly updated
and
and more even more sort of a by example
and and here we're really focusing on
solving rather than
encoding problems with maxa due to the
time constraints
but let me continue hopefully this will
bring something
new to some of the participants but this
is uh
rather high level and and non-technical
still
so so what we're talking about today is
maxat or maximum satisfiability and ss
jakob already
uh spelled it out so this is a
exact boolean optimization paradigm that
essentially builds on on boolean
satisfiability solving and it's
it's it's remarkable success
uh and and really takes sat solvers
and and applies them iteratively to
solve optimizations
uh problems and uh due to the
yeah the great progress is made in
recent years in in the in the servers
there's
there's really an expanding range of
real world applications where max up is
is the declarative optimization paradigm
of choice even so it really offers an
alternative for example and more
to more classical uh approaches
such as of course one has to mention
mixed integer programming
and uh and in microsoft of course we can
provide probably optimal solutions we
can even
in principle provide proofs um
yeah and and it's really uh since we're
modeling problems with logic
so it's just like in sat this is very
much a suited
paradigm especially in cases where the
problems
underlying problems that we want to
solve uh
yield sort of natural encodings in logic
but but this
branches onto just like the success of
sad to
more and more uh heterogeneous domains
problem dominance
so i'll give a brief motivation and
basic concepts
uh and then we'll turn to the core part
of the
the the talk with namely uh max that
solving and we're really focusing on
and on particular uh types of algorithms
that have turned out to be some of the
most successful ones
when we will cover both complete and
so-called complete and incomplete
algorithms
yeah so of course when we talk about sat
we
that's your problem so we were given a
propositional logic formula and we asked
whether it's satisfiable and it's and
and hope we all know by now uh attending
the summers institute
series and and all the other
developments going on that
southeast indeed a great success story
not just a theoretical
tool uh and this is due to sat solvers
and and why i'm mentioning this again is
that
when it comes to maxsat and building
maxset solvers
the the the most important thing is that
we have subsolvers that can prove
the non-existence of solutions and in
particular
provide explanations for the known
existence of solutions uh
so yeah and there's of course been this
great uh
uh remarkable improvement in sat solvers
but i'll show you a similar plot
for maxat but the point is yeah we're
using these core mp
search procedures sub solvers to
for optimization and why do we want i uh
why why is optimization interesting
it's because one could even claim that
most often in the real world
there's some sort of an objective that
we need to
more uh minimize or maximize in terms
of so so we want to find the best
solutions whatever
best means and it depends on your domain
we might want to
find the least resource consuming
schedule shortest
something uh most resource consuming can
mean many things
you know human resources money
what not or we might want to find
smallest explanations
in debugging configuration or even
explaining
say machine learning models
so there is indeed high demand for
automated approaches to finding good
solutions or
ideally optimal solutions to
computationally hard optimization
problems and and this is where microsoft
today
uh pops in uh we
we're not gonna talk about much much at
all about applications
there's a lot of reason as i already
said
drastically increasing number of success
successful applications of maxsite
in various types of domains uh
here are some sort of high level titles
for the types of problems that moxat has
been successful in recently
i would actually advise people to pick
up the the
now very much up and coming
second volume or edition of the uh
handbook on sat where where there's an
updated uh
chapter on maxsat where some of these
domains are discussed a bit more and and
there's also
plenty of references to check out
but i have a question regarding this
impressive list
it's a slightly vague question but let's
see if i can
make it to make sense when
i go to this ai conference i get the
feeling that some
applications for say sat swallowing or
answers at programming or or maxat or
whatever
are more like applications in academia
that researchers have figured out that
in principle you can do this and then
they code it up and they evaluate it
and some applications are more like
maybe actually in industry
you know being deployed to solve real
problems
um definitely like my understanding is
that for sat solders that
you know intel and other companies are
actually using these tools to verify
their processor
designs for instance do do you have
anything to say about like
what kind of math sets applications are
actually deployed and
which one are more at the academic stage
if the question makes sense
yeah it does it's it's a it's a tough
question dog because i'm i'm i'm
i work in the academia but uh
as you mentioned intel for example let
me
give a short answer and a very quick
answer to your weight question
so um one example it comes from intel
where people at intel are are actually
developing some of the state-of-the-art
tools
for maxat and and surely there is uh
surely there's a reason why they are
doing that
uh so i think in just like in in in
saath there's
problems that really are uh
sort of nicely formulated with logic and
and i believe this sort of extends to
optimization as well
enough thanks
yeah and all these these improvements
are really
sort of why these all these applications
are popping up
are due to the fact that microsoft
solvers are are getting more and
more efficient and that's why we're
talking about the algorithms today
uh and i maybe i'll continue within
with my answer to jakob i should say
that
when there's a chance of beating the
state-of-the-art commercial
mixed integer programming tools then
i believe it's in itself clear that
that these solvers can be used
in in in beyond academia
yeah so so uh so just to make it
more illustrative so probably you've
seen these plots for
sat solver reformers so the higher the
better
nowadays uh you used to be the more
right the better but now it's
the higher the better so essentially
what we've seen
uh within the last say 10 years is is a
similar progress than we've seen a
start a bit earlier for slot solvers now
it's happening for maxat solvers
so essentially if you take there's take
standard benchmarks and run them on on
the best
uh solver implementations from
different years in in a maxat evaluation
you will see
really on the same hardware you will see
that there is
indeed evident progress
from from year to one year to the next
okay so basic concept so uh just to make
sure that everyone's on the same page so
we're talking about muksad so
again in in its purest form uh we
our input is just a set of clauses so
conjunctive normal form formula
and and we're asked to find a a
satisfying truth assignment that that
satisfies as many of the causes in the
in the formula as possible
yes and this is of course in its purest
form oxide and and what's what's
typically
uh how it's presented in in in
uh complexity uh books and and and
things
like that but of course this is not that
convenient for modeling practical
problems
and that's why we nowadays when i say
maxi we mean essentially weighted
partial oxide
so we can we can associate weights
uh weights with with clauses so we can
have weighted
soft clauses or soft constraints and
then
of course we can we can uh associate
infinite weights to some clauses meaning
that they are hard they have to be
satisfied by any solution
and so if you if you're allowed to deem
some
causes as hard you talk about prison
oxide and then if you're allowed to use
non-unit
weights on soft clauses then talk about
weighted max sets so we're talking about
weighted
partial maximum
um so here's a a neat example that we're
going to use
to illustrate all of the algorithms that
we're going to talk about today so pay
attention this is not to say that this
is a state over they are
max that is a state of the art approach
to finding shortest paths
in grids uh but uh
this is just for illustrational purposes
because because it's nicer to have
something concrete to
illustrate algorithms on rather than
just clauses
um hopefully this will work out well to
you as well so
okay so the point is that we we we're
get we're in a grid
uh so there's a start uh cell and and a
goal cell
so we want to find a path uh
using horizontal and vertical moves
going from s to g
and we want to find the shortest path
from s to g
and there's some blocked squares that we
can't uh
enter go through uh so here for example
a shortest path would go from
from s to a c d e l
r that's one and g that's one short
stuff
as i said so this is really to for from
here
illustration but you'll also now see the
only encoding that you see in the talk
so how do we encode this in in in maxi
and so we need to take some boolean
variables so here's sort of a
unitary encoding so we take
for each uh unblocked grid square
a boolean variable and associates the
grid's name with the with the variable
so it's
s g a b and so forth and and and
its intended uh meaning is each of these
variables is that it's it's true if and
only if
the passing the square in question is
visited by
our path that we're constructed
and now the constraints so so to start
off
we can oppose see immediately two
constraints so we need to visit
s and we need to visit g because we want
to find a path from s to g
so we're going to impose unit heart
clauses
s and g that forbid all solutions where
smg is not
in and now
since we want to find the shortest path
we can penalize
including each particular cell to the
path
um by by these soft
unit constraints so we have soft clauses
of weights
one uh namely stating that
unless you do not visi and you unless
you do not not visit a
a so then you will get a penalty of one
meaning that if you enter a in the path
a is on the path
you construct then you're gonna get a
penalty f1
and now we need to still enforce the
existence of a path between s
and g with your additional hard clauses
right so one way to think about it is
that
we're gonna leave from s and we're gonna
end up in
g so we need to uh
have exactly one visited neighbor for
both s and g
and then all of the other squares that
are visited
by our path need to have exactly two
visited neighbors one
predecessor and one successor
okay so so exactly one visited neighbor
this is quite easy
so uh in logic so propositional logic so
the neighbors of s
and a are a and b so we need to state an
exactly one constraint over a and b
so a plus b is one and it's just the
exclusive or
over a and b so it's it's
which is the closest a or b and and not
a or not b
in conjunctive normal form
similarly for g well it has three
neighbors and we should visit exactly
one of them
so it gets a bit more hairy because we
have more than two
uh neighbors to talk about so at least
one is easy it's just the clause
say saying we see k q or
r and at most one in cnf
we can for example state with pairwise
disallowing
all pairs over the three
grid positions so so not k or not q
and so forth
and now to talk about the intermediate
uh squares
or grid cells on our path we need to say
that
each of them if they are on the path
then they have to have exactly two
visited neighbors
so now it's sort of a conditional uh or
rafael constraints saying that if if
we take the penalty of uh including
e for example on our path
then uh there's exactly two of
d j l and f uh the horizontal and
vertical neighbors of e
that are visited by the path okay
now this of course requires encoding the
cardinality constraint over
here in cnf but the good thing
is that without going any in more into
detail
there's this is of course cardinality
constraints pop up all over the place in
in the real world so so the sad
community has
has developed quite efficient and
compact encodings for
such things so we know that this can be
done
and these are just hard causes so it's
just a subtle encoding
so the it's just a starting coding ins
with an addition of the soft clauses
units of courses that
penalize uh visiting the individual grid
cells or expression
and that's why i'm accelerating
uh so yeah so now this gives us any
solution will give us
a some sort of a path and then uh
a maxat solution or an optimal max such
solution would be then
something that that
violates uh as few as possible of the
units of constraints for example the
green path so an optimal solution
has cost eight in in this
this particular grid
okay so remember this we're going to use
this you will see this script
later on um but yeah
just the word on the complexity so so of
course deciding whether whether cake
clauses
over of a given cnn formula can be
satisfied that's an np complete problem
it's quite easy to see uh because
satisfy complete
so what what we can essentially
algorithmically do is iterate over the
the k and and and and for example with
linear research
and to find a an optimal uh
uh solution to pure marxite instances
and and then it's actually sort of fp np
complete
uh so in in general so we we essentially
just need a polynomial number of sub
oracle course
in practice and this is really what's
what's what's what's done
we have our first question mati uh or
second i guess i already asked one
first one in the chat uh so are the at
most constraints
necessary in the encoding for the
shortest paths they're necessary for the
sat solar to produce a valid
path but the max at solver will remove
dead ends anyway
right
that is a very good question
[Music]
i would say that that you're writing
that that most constraints are not
needed
but in practice i'd assume that assad
solver does
better if you include them they lead to
more propagation and give you more
information
so the individual calls will be faster
but
formally speaking you would not need
them to get a correct encoding but
you'll get a better one
yeah you still can't produce yeah
psychos
she clicks up tours so it should be fine
yeah that's that's
that's right yeah
stefan doesn't agree that might be true
actually
good question unrooted circles
yeah that's that's the scare of it so
yeah i thought this through once i had
this
question before so yeah the issue could
be that you could have sort of
sub uh tours that are disconnected
so just to point out because i think
when this is being uh sent on on youtube
people can't see the chat that we see so
stefan got is writing i think you could
have
unrooted circles without the at most
constraints and this could lead to an
unconnected
path
i mean it's true that the fact that this
encoding is correct seems to use this
parity
argument that only the source and the
sink have
odd parity right yeah
so if i'm allowed to disconnect then
i'll make a small
cycle somewhere around the source and
another small single
circle with a fork somewhere around the
sink and now i have a really short path
so it might be that it's actually needed
and some bus is having the same concern
that if you re
i think sam is saying that if we remove
this this would not force the end nodes
to be connected i think we're using like
the parity argument to connect
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i i think so
yeah i had to think this through i had
this i should remember the answer to
this question because i had this
question before okay
so um so but let me continue so
so we'll use this for illustration of
the algorithms and so you'll see
sort of the algorithm work on the grid
rather than cnf uh
okay so yeah and just like in sat
solvers uh
there's these are maxwell solvers are
push button
uh solvers so so you don't really need
command line parameters
especially for the complete solvers and
and and there's a there's just like for
sub solvers there's the
dynamic cnf format there's the dimex
wcnf format
which essentially differs only in in
in that that where this is a clause
uh over the variable indexes one two and
three and then
x1 is negated uh there's there's
uh before the clause is the first thing
on on each line there's a
a uh weight and and there's
there's a so-called top weight that
allows you to uh
state that particular clause is hard
so sort of representing infinite weight
essentially
uh oh so in the format there are no
hard clauses but you have to make them
hard by
making ridiculously large weights so
this is this
is uh perhaps should
the standard if you ask me personally
the standard should be changed then one
could use the
letter h for example to start a hard
clause
because computing the top is also a bit
uh not so nice and then what you see is
people
develo uh producing sat maxi instances
uh the interpretation of which can
depend on the solver because
of the how they're parsed and then
whether whether for example the top
is assumed to actually refer to
something
that's exactly stating what's a hard
clause or
and and whatnot so there's actually some
problems with this
and then this would be nice to change oh
you mean if i add a
if i give a top value that is actually
too low then it might be solver
dependent whether this is treated as a
hard clause or a soft clause with this
particular weight
yes that sounds scary and and
also so if you sum up the the weights
for the soft clauses
should the top be higher than that and
then you know you get representational
issues
as well if you don't know what's the
optimal solution
and the cost of an optimal solution
right
uh what the what should the top be
and then if you sum up all the the
weights that could be a ridiculously
large number simply is noting this in
the
chat also this seems to be platform
dependent
uh yeah okay but this is the format we
have for today yes we're not going to
change it before the end of the seminar
unfortunately no
uh yeah and and then so yeah
and and as i show you showed you the
plot that i mentioned maxed evaluations
there is this uh
annual event called maxi evaluation that
just like in such competitions uh aims
to assess the state of the art
in max ad solvers and then produce these
benchmark sets that
can be used in research work and then
developing
further solvers and uh
this is not a as huge as the sub
competition series in terms of the
number of participants that but there
are various solvers
each year being evaluated it's not a
competition per se
but seems to be more of an evaluation
with the less
strict criteria for um
for participating uh
and and nowadays there's tracks for both
complete and incomplete solvers that
we're gonna talk about
today
um yeah and i should mention that
oh i do mention it okay so yeah so max
that solver is just a practical so it's
an implementation of an algorithm for
finding
solutions to max given oxide instances
complete solvers are guaranteed to find
optimal solutions
so probably optimal solutions to any
instance given if resources and
and incomplete solvers are essentially
tailored
uh whereas complete solvers are tend to
be
allowed to use a lot of resources
incomplete solvers are tailored towards
producing
relatively good solutions whatever the
interpretation of that means
is to even very large
instances uh fairly quickly
so for example uh the in the evaluations
the complete solvers are given
for instance time limit around one hour
whereas
incomplete are run for a minute or five
minutes per instance
but there needs to for incomplete there
needs to be no guarantees on how good
the solutions are really
uh yeah when it comes to maxed
evaluation i want to mention that
nowadays we have an
open resource open source uh requirement
uh a few years back uh
and before that the the solways were
mostly available in binary but nowadays
uh
we're trying to really make people
produce
open source maxset solvers because this
is how this
part of the reason why sat is such a
success so that
anyone can build on on previous solvers
and hopefully this will be picked up on
more and more okay so let's now get to
the algorithms
uh uh so and we'll cont
start with the complete algorithms and
and in the end we'll get to the
incomplete ones which actually
mix sort of ideas from complete solvers
so that's why actually you noticed the
iphones in in the
the incomplete uh solver description a
couple of slides ago
so that tried to refer to the fact that
they're some of the incomplete solvers
if you run them for
enough long long enough they will
actually provide optimal solutions
but it really depends on on the
algorithmic foundation of the
source so when it comes to uh complete
solvers there's you can categorize the
the main
sort of uh mainstream algorithmic
approaches
developed uh as follows so there's
there's a branch
sort of a specialized branch inbound
approach
that can be very effective on on small
but hard and randomly
generated instances in particular uh
but we we're not going to focus on this
today but we're going to talk about the
the the perhaps one can say more recent
developments
that that can scale to very very large
in
oxide instances and namely
these are all using to one
extent or another but to a far extent
in any case sat solvers
and and when it comes to these sat based
maxi algorithms there's essentially
three
three types of uh uh
approaches so-called model improving
approaches
uh uh core guided approaches
and and the implicit hitting the
approach
and and and due to the fact that well
due to the time constraints and and also
due to the fact that
well the core guided approach is
implemented
by by the the the greatest number of
of solvers nowadays available and and
and
core guided together the implicit
hitting set approach
turns out to be quite effective
knowledge so we'll we'll outline uh
these approaches
and then uh after that we'll turn to
incomplete and
and and and explain how how how to
combine some of the ideas from these
approaches and different ideas as well
towards
incomplete sort
so but just very shortly i mentioned
model improving
so what does this mean so it essentially
refers to
searching for for the optimal bound uh
on the cost uh from top
top down uh in terms of the cost
function range
so so so we just
instantiate the the upper bound
to be uh all the number of soft clauses
when we talk about unweighted instances
and then we can ask essentially so
whether we can set it
where the the sat solver can find a
better solution always
so can you answer uh can we use
leave unset it's or falsified less than
the current bound number of clauses so
can you satisfy more clauses
than the currently best solution found
and and as long as you find a satisfying
uh
truth assignment with a set solver to
this query then you update the
your your working formula with a tighter
bound
so this is essentially a cardinality
constraint
that we're adding each time to the sub
solver and asking again
and uh as if we do this by linear search
from
top down then and of course uh
immediately when the set solver says no
there's no solution you
we know that the previous solution was
was an optimal
so this approach can be quite efficient
does it make sense at all to consider
binary search in this setting
rather than linear research yeah
this can be done and and it has been
also proposed
uh but i i believe
there's no really in the current sort of
state of the art there's no solver that
does
that's a binary search
get any assignment i'm right on this i i
i don't i'm not aware of one
so there used to be earlier on yeah
there used to be earlier on one that
combined this model improvement with
so-called core guided but it's it's
it's sort of gone away
okay fair enough yeah so so model
improving can be very efficient when
when the when the actual optimal cost is
quite high
so you can't really satisfy minutes of
causes because then you're going to
germinate quite quickly
um and and there are solvers that
use variants of this algorithm so once
you don't totally disregard this at all
so
there are cases where this is can be
very effective
and and going beyond complete that's the
otherness will spell out
in more detail later this this approach
is
indeed applied yeah
together with other things in in the
realm of incomplete selling
so just adding that there's a comment
from armin biere in the chat
that explained last time that binary
search
risks to overshoot the best solution
quite a bit
uh and this produces large
formulas oh because you have to
re-encode every time i guess yeah also
yeah well it's one of these clashes of
theory and practice right as a
theoretician of course
you should do binary search except in
practice you don't want to do it
yeah yeah i i i think
it the because
it's really dependent on the instance
and and its optimal cost
yeah there's it feels like there's
always instances on which it will not
work well
because of this what armin wrote
so it will overshoot when there's an
opportunity to overshoot
uh yes
okay but we'll turn to now core guide it
uh and and as a prequel to core guided
yeah
we'll talk about core guided more in a
moment but let me just
uh spell out that just like you can do
model improving from top down you can go
bottom up
and do you could do lower bound search
of course
and and and you would just go ahead and
ask if you can satisfy
all soft clauses and this is of course
what what you would do
for that's the first step in essentially
any maxat algorithm
that uses a sub solver because this is a
very cheap first check
um
uh okay so uh and and and then you can
just
you know go on to ask okay what okay is
there
a worse solution if this one doesn't
have a solution
and this is quite bad now because
now we don't have even a solution
and and when you go on and do this
you have to use these cardinality
constraints just like in model
improvement
but you don't really get
information from these unsub cases
if you don't do something else if you
don't rely on what the solver
can really provide us or if i disturb
mate i'm just adding one more comment
from the chat here so that everybody
can hear it that in constraint
programming it's usually
that only a few values on either side of
the objective are really hard but
sometimes you get nasty instances where
even a lot over the objective is really
hard these are particularly nasty for
binary search
rights kieran mccree sorry for
interrupting please go on
yeah yeah approaching the up but
approaching an optimal bond can be very
hard
yeah if you approach it sort of
carefully
i think it's also for the model
improving it's a challenge
okay yeah but the point is that that you
don't really get information
if you don't use some additional
information that the solver provides us
and this is why this approach
in it in like this is not really
implemented at all
but but the now the point is that we we
can use more
information from the solver because we
can get unsatisfiable course
that that give us hints towards what
what subsets of the soft clauses are
conflicting with each other and
producing conflicts
and and now we can actually stay
essentially
start relaxing these soft clauses
using this core information and in this
course
what they yield are much tighter
cardinality constraints
towards an optimal solution and now this
is essentially what the core guided
solvers do
and and and this is how you can scale to
millions of variables so just to state
uh uh by an example so if you have a cnn
formula that's unsatisfiable
anything that that's unsatisfiable that
a subset of the clauses that's
unsatisfiable is called an unsatisfiable
core
and and what we would hope that this is
that the solver provides us
a small unsatisfiable course because
then we can uh
do these uh uh impose this tighter
cardinality constraints when when
at the next iteration of the solving
agreement
and of course in max the point is that
the the course
talk about soft clauses so the hard
constraints are sort of a
background theory so you do always these
checks
all hard causes on and then
you have soft clauses a subset of soft
causes that together with the hard
causes
are unsatisfiable and the cores are
starts to talk about this subset of
software
there's a question are these onset cores
computed only for the soft clauses to
blend them out
asks i hope i i hope i
just said it yes
not too many words yes exactly so the
hard clauses are always there but
they're not in the don't
occur in the in the course themselves
so uh now we're getting to this
illustration
uh that we're gonna use for the
algorithm so for example
remember our shortest path problem
and now what we have is the heart
constraint stating that
s has to be visited and
and because we visit s we have to visit
exactly one of a and b
now we have the soft clauses stating
that don't visit a
don't visit b well i would prefer you
not so is it a i would prefer you not so
is it b
uh so now uh if if you add
this you have these clauses uh at these
clauses and the hardclone states the
subserver the solver will say onsat
and and one of the cores it can return
is exactly
these uh the the
the clause that rep is the
the negation of of consists of the
negations of these
unit clauses and that's a chord because
what the chord is really stating is that
if any path that goes from s to g
has to go through a or b so you cannot
satisfy both of these soft clauses so
that's an onset core in website
okay all right so now
i'll let's let's allow rms to pick
up uh on on this end and and
give you details on some of the core
guided arguments
yes thank you you need to stop sharing
so i can insurance that
so hello everyone nice to see so many
people here
and i'll continue from the exact next
slide
i hope it's visible now
so as matt already mentioned core guided
algorithms
are the one type that is mostly
implemented by the solvers
that are that are available today
starting from 2006 with the so-called
true molecular
algorithm there's been new solvers
almost every year not five but but
as recently as last year
and there are various differences
between these
they use various different heuristics
and clever tricks
which are a bit too subtle for me to
have time to go into here
so what i want to do instead is to focus
on sort of
two high level views on how to use
the course the first one
i'll call one an approach where you take
all of the course that you find
and then you relax them together
and the second one is where you try to
use make as much use of the information
provided by individual parts as possible
by relaxing the course separately these
boldenings of solver names should be
taken with a grain of salt as i already
said many solvers
use also sort of combinations of these
techniques
but on a really high level and a bit
roughly you could separate the
correlated algorithms into these two
groups okay
so first starting with the approach
where you try to relax the course
together
which is implemented by others among
others by the so-called msu-3 algorithm
here we start by initializing a set that
i'll call r
to be the soft clauses that need to be
relaxed
or the squares that we can visit in this
example
and a lower bound initially we have the
lower bounds that this is zero
then we ask the sat solver can we find a
solution
that satisfies all of our heart clauses
and unsatisfies at most lower bound from
the set r
so instantiated here we're asking for a
path
that visits at most our lower bound
amount of nodes from the set r so
initially we're asking is there a path
that goes through no nodes
in the set r and this is this is of
course unsatisfiable
and the sat solver will give us an
explanation for why it's
why it is unsatisfiable one of these
cores
so say it return gives you this one
containing a and b
like matti said that they form a core
and now we can then update our set r
to include the nodes a and b and also
increase the lower bound so in the next
iteration
we are asking is there a path that
visits
at most one node from the set r that now
contains a
and b and no others so can we go from s
to g
via only one node from a or b
and this is still unsatisfiable
and we'll get a new core say for example
the one containing
c the nodes c and g or the soft clauses
corresponding to these nodes
and then we again bump up our lower
bound and keep going
in the fifth iteration we might have
found chords corresponding
containing all of the notes here in grey
and now we're asking for a a where's the
sixth generation i think actually
we're asking for a path that goes
through these gray nodes
but at most five of them and we still
can't find one
and we get our but then we get our final
core
and asking that solver for a path that
goes through at most
six of the nodes in this set and now it
finds one
which we then which we then return as an
optimal solution
and the enemies are you going to tell me
where these numbers
came from uh which numbers
this two increased to five to six
uh it's just a basic uh sort of lower
bound linear search we're trying to find
a cost a solution goes zero if we can't
we then have to say well how about a
solution of cost one
and then if we can't we bump it up to
two
and then we keep going until we find the
first bound
where we can find the solution so it's
just we start from the trivial lower
bound of zero
and then we keep increasing it until we
get satisfiable
so the difference to this naive approach
is that we're not considering
all of the soft clauses we're not
allowing the sat solver to falsify all
soft classes
but only soft classes that have appeared
in some of the course
that we find along the way
okay so so in this particular example
we end up with not having to consider
this subclass corresponding to the o
here
at all so we'll just keep on saying that
you're not supposed to visit it
if we're only allowing the falsification
of the soft process corresponding to
these gray notes
not all of them which is the difference
between this and the
naive lower bonding search that what we
talked about
and i've noticed in what the
presentation that i'm actually saying
in my examples we're not going to incur
cost for the starting or
goal node so hence the cost of an
optimal solution for me is going to be
six
so we visit six nodes along the way
that's a
minor difference sorry about that
so this algorithm can be quite
efficient and it is used in practice and
solvers that exist today
and especially if the course that you
find are fairly small
then you don't have to relax
then the set of soft clauses you end up
relaxing is small
and if if you can find a solution
of a low cost so remember that here
we're starting from zero
and then we're just bumping it up in
unweighted case by one
each time so if your optimal solution
has a low cost
then you don't have to do that many
iterations and hence you might
be able to terminate quicker
so i have another technical question
so the this fact that you're allowed to
falsify and so on so many of the soft
clauses this will now be encoded in cnf
in some
nifty way that you have for encoding
your cardinality constraints
yeah this is exactly i think it was
going to be my my next sentence would be
that the
problem or the challenge of this that
you still have to do a cardinality
constraint
that says you're only allowed to falsify
at most so and so many clauses
and then i'm wondering if we are we
perhaps also using here
i think which i think is a standard
trick in max at solving but i'm not sure
if it's obvious to everybody that
without loss of generality you can have
like a pre-processing step
where you rewrite your problem so that
all the soft clauses are actually unit
clauses and that's why you guys
minimize the sum of the blocking
variables right exactly
this is you said this and i missed it
but uh we
didn't and and this is a very good point
if you want to talk about how to
actually implement these solvers but in
practice
all of the implementations of all
algorithms that i'm aware of
do this trick so so we can assume that
any kind of soft clauses that you have
are going to be of this form
with a unique negative literal if you
have an instance where that's not true
then you just simply
take a new literal add that to your
original soft clause
treat that as hard and then add the new
literal as a unification as soft
this is a sort of technical important
technical detail
that you need when you but if you want
to implement your max ads solver you can
contact me and i'll
tell you more about that
and now the other problem we might think
of that
we might take you up on that promise you
know just
i'm good
so in addition to the fact that you
still need this cardinality constraint
which can be a bit tricky and can be a
bit large
another problem with this relaxing whole
course that one
approach is that you sort of in a
certain certain sense you lose
information that the course could
provide you're not making full use of
this course
so if you go back to the same example
and look at what's happening in the
third iteration
as i said we are now asking asking the
set solver
for a path that visits at most two of
these gray nodes
and goes from s to g
however based on the course that we
extracted we actually know something
stronger matti already alluded to this
we
extracted a core containing the clauses
corresponding to a
and b and the fact that it is a core
says
that any path between s and g has to go
through
either a or b and similarly for the
second car we also know that any path
needs to go through either c or g
so this constraint here is in a certain
sense too loose
we know that the solutions to this here
which for example
would set c to true and g to true
are not going to correspond to actual
models but
in this algorithm we're not telling the
sat solver this we're not
letting it make you make use of this
knowledge that we have
just by core extractions
and carlos is saying in the chat that
that you can also use different
cardinality constraints for
non-overlapping course
yeah and this goes and that's absolutely
absolutely true and for this type of
algorithm this
this picking your cardinality constraint
smartly when you have non-overlapping
cores is one of the key features
that makes it effective this example
here is a bit easy because all of your
cores are non-overlapping
but it can but there are some clever
things you can do
if for more complex instances
but the way in which the way in which i
want to take this from here
is instead to talk about this second
alternative that i mentioned
which is to make use of this information
by relaxing each core
separately
so if we go back to the same example
this time around we're taking a
so-called working instance
which i denote by h0 the initial part
clauses
and s0 the initial soft clauses
and then we first asked the set solver
for a model that would satisfy all of
the hard pauses and all of the soft
clauses
so implicitly the first poll is asking
do we have a
do we have a solution to this maxwell
problem that has cost
zero
but more importantly in this case we can
also see this call
to ask for a this will get clearer in a
second but i'll say
for the first time now the call is
asking
for a path that goes visits at most one
node from each of the found cores
so initially we have no cores so we're
asking
for a path of length zero of one that
visits at most one node from each of our
zero cores and
similarly to before this is of course
unsatisfiable and we get a core
and now this time around we relax this
core immediately into the instance so in
the sense we're encoding
the information provided by this core
into the instance
itself we're saying okay
so a and b the soft clauses a and b form
a core
so in subsequent iterations you're
allowed to falsify
at most one of them because we know that
any optimal solution has to
falsify at most one of them
so we go back to that solver and now we
know that we need to falsify at least
one clause we've found one course
for it so we know that we have to
falsify at least once of course
and now we're asking that solver is
there a path that visits
at most one from this one chord that we
actually found
and still we cannot get to the goals
goal node
so the next core we might get from the
solver might be at something like this
this is saying that you need to visit at
least one of these nodes
and now we can again do the same thing
we re-relax the instance saying
okay so in in subsequent iterations
you're allowed to falsify
one node from this core and one node
from this core
and then we go back and then we keep
going
until we found enough of this cores
to actually allow us to terminate after
we found
i think it's five six cores
we now ask is there a path between the
start and the goal nodes that visits
at most one node from each phone course
so in other words
goes through a node of a specific color
at most one time
and this time around we can of course
find one
and the sad solver can return
satisfiable and we get our model and
we're happy
so in comparison to the earlier
algorithm this time
the cardinality encodings are
are in a certain sense tighter
and we don't need to explicitly maintain
the lower bound
and the set of course as i said as soon
as we get a new car
uh we'll encode it encode the
information into the formula itself and
you don't need to maintain it
and and the fact that the lower bound
increases by one
sort of follows from the number of ports
that we find in this unweighted case for
each core that we find
we can we increase the lower bound by
one but in practical implementations
you don't need to care about what your
lower bound is you just keep going until
the set solver
gives you satisfiable and then you can
check
what the cost of that model was
so as i said the first instantiation of
this kind of an idea was by foo and
malik in 2006
and that was sort of the kickoff into
the research of core guided algorithms
and nowadays most of the existing
solvers
that use this approach implement the
so-called oll algorithm which i believe
fahim also talked about which was this
was first proposed
in the context of answer set programming
and then
extended to max ad in 2014.
there are differences between these and
the differences are mainly in
how how these relaxations that what kind
of clauses you add
to relax the chords of course and in
practice
it's quite clear that the algorithm is
the one you want to use at the moment
at least until someone comes up with a
better one
and as i already talked about in
comparison to the other algorithm
algorithm this time we only need
cardinality constraints saying
at most one of the clauses in each core
can be satisfied at least at most one
constraints
tend to be more effective for sat solver
to reason over
which is a nice nice thing
to have but then on the flip side now
you need
many different cardinality constraints
one for each core
and there's also been some work in
showing that when you try to extract the
core from this new formula
that can uh doing so can be
exponentially harder
than from the original formula
especially
or i would say actually only if you have
this overlapping course
so as long as your cores are
non-overlapping that's no problem but as
soon as you have overlapping course you
might end up
having a harder time finding your course
and i guess that's it for my first part
about this complete algorithms
next it would be we would move on to the
implicit heating set
algorithms which what did we talk about
but would this be a good time to have a
break
maybe i was just going to ask you i
think
it is um and before we
officially take a break are there any
questions at this point from anyone i
mean we've had a few questions in the
chat
yeah thank you if anything has been
those we've taken care of but anyone
else based on the material so far any
questions from
anyone
otherwise while you're thinking that's
what will happen now is we'll take a
uh 10 minute break give or take
um can i answer the question yes read it
out and answer please
victor is asking how does one actually
find the course
and in practice you use the assumption
interface
provided by most of the set solvers that
exist
so you call your set you add this you
call your chat solvers
while assuming your soft clauses
in a way that would satisfy them if you
remember i said that in practice you use
these unit
literals as soft clauses and then both
of these add solvers today are able if
the result is unset
the set solvers can give you back a
subset of your
assumptions which is enough to explain
unsatisfiability
and that subset will correspond to the
core so we use
that solvers in a black box manner to do
this
uh the second question from armin are
people considering to use cardinality
constraints natively
or at most one conference instead of
encoding
yes yes for sure people are and i think
don't quote me on this but i think the
maxino
microsolver actually even uses tb
constraints to some extent
natively in our work
we we've had some
problems getting that to be as effective
as encoding or more generally speaking
having these separate
sort of propagators to be more effective
as
as encoding but that's an interesting
direction for sure
i just can't resist saying
that there is also a pseudo boolean
solver that does
[Music]
yeah it's interesting but i mean so it's
interesting that it seems that
uh it doesn't seem to really pay off to
try to do native uh cardinality
constraints
at least in inside
so maybe it's about the explanations
like if you put them as propagators
you're
the learning just you know
that the learning is actually important
and then i think it depends on how you
how you use them in the conflict
analysis also i
i think that could make a big difference
i mean
once you're moving to to to uh
suitable and constraints you can do all
kinds of things like you can extract
cores that are actually not just clauses
but pseudo boolean
have you done that we have this in
in the paper that i put in the chat
we're actually extracting the cores are
not clauses they're general generic
pseudo boolean constraints
uh and then we round them to cardinality
constraints in order to update the
objective function but
in principle you could i think ember
demirovich
suggested doing some kind of you can
extract a generic
as like a general pseudo boolean core
and then try to do some kind of dynamic
programming to see how to update the
objective function in the best way
there are all kinds of tricks you could
try to pull but also the suitable and
conflict analysis might give you better
course in the first place
even if you're
to me it's quite unclear uh
whether one can really make the would
make this payoff uh
but uh yeah i agree it's not clear
that's right but that's exactly why i
said that the promise jeremias made
just a few minutes ago is a risky one
right i think it's a very interesting
question i'm somewhat optimistic but i
don't know
and i'm obviously a little bit of an
outsider but i'm learning as we speak
um
[Music]
constraint is that constraint
programming solvers use resolution and
it works
lazy clause generation constraint
programming servers i don't know amy
do you want to undo this speak maybe or
do i need to unmute
you i can allow you to speak
do you mean to say that the propagators
are not needed
no so can you hear me now yes we hear
you yeah i was just saying that
so in lazy class generation um
constraint programming solvers
when we still use the resolution proof
system and there
we would use this kind of native support
for carnality constraints
so it's just that you said that you
don't think that in max that it would be
useful
which could be true maybe but still like
in since constraint programming
it seems to be useful then there's some
thing there's some evidence that it
could be also useful in maxim
yeah i think the point is that what you
start off with
is this extremely low level format uh
like if you that's why i said if you
stick with maxad
it's much more unclear to me whether it
can pay off
compared to if you start with something
that's a higher level declaration
or your problem i don't think i don't
think it's a matter of the proof system
or so but it's just that like
effectiveness of
solvers well it was more like that in
cp it wouldn't generate additional like
for example in max at you
so i think the difference is you you
would add additional variables to the
encoding
and these additional variables are very
useful compared to just using a
trivial explanation let's say so what i
was saying that
the true the additional variables you
introduce are very valuable for mac
centers
but cp doesn't typically doesn't use
these additional variables
but it's still but it still works which
is remarkable in a sense it's a bit
surprising
but it's true that indeed there's no
real
work on combining this kind of
constraint programming style with
max set
yeah i it can also be that you know
this this specific approaches that we
have right now
don't really work with these ideas and
you
have to think out of the box more not to
try to build on what you
already have right yeah definitely
so i don't see any further questions so
maybe let's
now take uh you know ten
ish minutes a break enough to grab a cup
of coffee and then we'll resume
i guess let's say yeah so 11 minutes
to the hour so the brick is officially
on now
so we are resuming in one or two minutes
that is assuming that our speakers are
still available
i don't know if there are any questions
that have arisen during the break
thomas has raised his hand
i think uh do i thomas maybe
should i since we're having the break
anyway could i promote you to panelists
maybe
trying that again since they're during
the break
anyone wants to be you know just go
ahead and promote some people
unless you protest you're not missing
anything
thanks jacob here we go
i'm in upgrade mode today
i don't know if it's the case also that
you'll have to tell me whether it's the
case that
attendees cannot send chat messages to
everybody i'm not sure i think it
but when you're sending chat messages
please make sure to send them to
both panelists and attendees except i'm
doing my best now to make sure that we
don't have any
attendees left and we don't have this
issue
i think both by by default
i was i in my chat since
only to panelist maybe you just have to
switch it
yes and attendees can send chats also to
everybody
yeah i guess i'm just experimenting
we're all learning this in this new
fantastic zoom world i just
took the liberty to upgrade everybody to
panelists i hope you don't mind i guess
you can
no antonina says that attendees can only
send messages to q and
a no i don't think that's true because i
know i also i also sent
messages to the chat when i was only
attendee
yeah they can yeah i think i also had
could also choose whether i wanted to
send to everyone or to penalize only
so we can try again you can download i'm
sorry uh i might be wrong because i seem
to remember
uh you might not be able to send
personal messages when you're not
engaged but you might be
sent to everybody i think personal
messages are
but this is also connecting back to what
we said at the beginning i think
chat rooms might be slightly different
in this regard you know but like
there might be customs and this is a
rich new world that we're all learning
to live
but i think antonina's right no personal
messages for it and this
so anyway i think we're good to go
um so i'll
again i'm monitoring the chat for
questions and
um sometimes reacting quickly and
sometimes not so quickly but the
speakers
can also i mean um it's good that jeremy
has
caught a number of chats that i missed
um
and everybody should now be able to
unmute and just ask questions so
i think let's just uh continue all right
yeah so i'll try to be fairly quick on
on this implicit hitting set part
because i i feel that there might be
overlap with
previous talks on this and and uh
and and it's good to give some time for
jeremy has to talk about the incomplete
part because that's
there's quite a bit of new developments
there
but yeah for about this implicit hitting
that algorithm for maxad so one should
first of all point out that this this uh
idea
general idea uh underlying uh this
algorithm
is is essentially founded in in writer's
early work on diagnosis and
and it's been used in various types of
settings and
you can use it for all sorts of hard
optimization problems uh
reasoning problems is associated with
different types of oracles not just sat
solvers and
ip solvers has done and in magsat
um but yeah so so so
uh jessica and fahim proposed this first
in their hs solver uh for for
maxat and and it's it's it's been quite
uh
influential and and and and it's
really uh one of the uh
main
uh approaches to microsoft solving these
days
um so heating said
i think everyone knows what's a hitting
set but of course we're given a
collection of sets
of elements over some universe and and
now
uh hitting set this then something a set
of these
uh set of elements from the universe
that
that include at least one element from
each of the
sets in our collection
and then here we're interested in
optimal hitting sets
essentially if we don't weigh have
weights on the elements then then we're
just interested in
in finding a smallest hitting set
and and if you would have weights on the
elements
then you would be interested in
finding a minimum cost heading set
so question regarding which actually i
guess so far we've
been unweighted but is there anything
that actually has
depended on the weight or like or would
everything you did so far extend
easily to like the weighted yes yeah so
the core guy that
so there's sort of a standard trick that
you need to know how to implement and no
one said how to implement it in your
paper but
anyway so you you can implement these
core guided
approaches they do work for weighted
partial maxat
no problem at all uh you essentially
when you extract the core and then
compile the core into your formula with
these cardinality constraints you sort
of consider its residual
residual weight of the clauses that were
in the course so you sort of
take out the minimum weight over the
the soft causes in the core and and and
if weight remains you still have those
soft causes
and that's how it sort of works andre
asked if there's a penalty in terms of
performance when you
get non-uniform weights
uh yes
yeah it's harder and and one of the
but it's it's very domain specific which
which uh solver is more effective so it
really is the case that it's
it's interesting that that when when it
comes to maxat these different
approaches really
uh have their different benefits and
this shows up
depending on the problem don't worry
which one to choose
you know if you compared to southwest
you know cdcbc
let's see so then on top of it all you
will have a
small machine learner that tells you
what to do or
not they're there if you want to do that
go ahead
you can do that yes
uh okay so what does this have to do
with max so
if we have an optimal hitting set of the
set of unsatisfiable cores of your maxat
instance so in our collection
of sets uh is the set of a collection of
unsatisfiable cores
of the instance where of which there's
plenty of course
exponential number of them so
if you compute any optimal hitting set
of the onsite course
then uh if you rule out the the soft
clauses
in that optimal hitting set and and
and you know that there's a there's
a solution to the rest of the
clauses in terms of salt so the rest of
the clauses are unsatisfiable
and that will be an optimal solution
to your max of distance because you
computed an optimal minimum cost hitting
set
uh ruling out all of the inconsistencies
so all of the cores
so you're you're sort of relaxing all of
the cores away
by computing and hitting there's only
one issue here so we
we don't want to complete the whole set
of unsatisfiable course right
because that's a big one
so that's what i said so so uh already
sorry so
the key insight is then that you just
want to find a hitting set of the onset
course
but you want to find it somehow
implicitly in hope hope
you just try to hit some calls and hope
for the best
and uh put it short distance to work
quite well
and then you just need to call a set
solver once you've been lucky
to get a solution and then you're done
so you need to do this of course
iteratively so you don't want to
compute a huge pile of course but you
want to compute
course fast so what iteratively is done
then
in the implicit eating approach you
accumulate a collection of onset course
or compute course
and then computer heating set over the
course and then
rule out those the soft clauses
in that hitting set you compute it from
the rest the next sub
solver call and then you get more cores
and then just compute another heading
set
until the set solver is this returns
a satisfying assignment that will be an
optimal search
and the hearing sets are in practice
computed just with an integer
programming solver
now i now i said that microsoft this is
can be integer programming and now we're
using integer programming inside max of
this
server isn't this interesting but the
interesting bit here is that we're
using it for it to solve a completely
different problem
it doesn't know anything about the
actual problem except for the costs
the the the weights of the unit clauses
and it just has this you know at least
one constraint the ip
of the min cost hitting set stating that
you need to hit this set
and and it doesn't know that it this
deals with max of course
uh but in in some sense now we're
sort of using ip at its best because it
doesn't really know much about the
problem but it can deal with these
course objective functions well
in a fairly unconstrained setting
and that solver is of course as good as
providing us course
and and now the difference of course
compared to
core guided approaches where you keep on
bloating up this the formula that you
the sub server is called on with this
card analytic constraint
you're not doing anything like that
you're using uh
assumption the assumptions interface to
sort of rule out some of the soft
clauses from consideration at each
iteration
and and so in hope that actually those
instances are
easier to solve rather than getting
bloated and harder to solve
and what's getting bloated gradually is
the ip
the mean cost hitting set ip
yeah i like to show this illustration
but this is again how it works so
essentially you give the cost function
uh
so the weights of the soft closest to
the mean cost hitting set
and then you start with the
you don't have a hitting set you don't
have any cores and then
at the first iteration you essentially
just check
with the sat solar if you can satisfy
all soft causes typically that tends
not to be the case in optimization so
you get a car
you add it to your set of cores which
was still empty
and then you ask for a trivial heating
set of one core
you get something you hit one soft cause
you remove that soft clause from
consideration for the next
set solver call and you keep on doing
this cycle
in principle like this until the set
service is set
and you're at adding optimal probably
optimal solution
uh things are not like don't work this
directly in in practice you have to pull
out a lot of tricks to make this really
really efficient
uh but the the still the underlying
framework is like this and as i said
this can be used for
anything because you have a core
extractor of
whatever your problem is and you have a
mean cost hitting set
or which can sort of have an arbitrary
objective function you just need
in principle you could do quadratic
objectives if you have a qp server
that's effective
and and you can have a qbf solver you
can have an smt solver you know
you know whatever so asp solver
anything that provides this course but
now we're talking about maxwell so
that's all
um okay so continuing with
our shortest first example this is maybe
a bit naive when it comes to uh
implicit hitting sets but let's see what
could happen
um so the intuition now is that
uh the heating sets are sort of guesses
of candidate
paths given the core information that we
currently have
and as long as we don't have enough core
information then there's no way of
the heating set providing sort of paths
to us
meaning of course the heating sets are
talking about those
those soft units of over the cells that
we don't satisfy which are exactly
the the the grid cells that we're
visiting on our path
so the healing sets try to talk about
the paths right
the path that we're constructing and the
satsura is trying
now verifying the candidate and
typically saying no no no no
no but you have to visit at least this
this cell and this cell
or this cell because this is not a path
okay so there's a question
uh that since you have this hitting set
problem
i mean that is also an optimization
problem and so you sort of can
ask why you don't run the max at solver
on it so
so nikolai asks can you explain can we
explain
why max had solvers are bad at mean
hitting set problems is it inherent
or for maxwell solvers using cdcl or
other
other explanations because nikolai used
the underline i
my short answer is no
no i no you can try it out
or you can do funky stuff like taking an
eye
implicit heating set solver and solve
the he needs a problem with that
no so but i i don't have a i don't have
a proper
uh idea but like feeding the max
the hitting set sub problem too to a max
that solver would
would not be a good idea you can do it
by pretty bad yeah the the uh
core guide it is really really bad at
these hitting set problems
i i tried so so uh if you have the lp
relaxation
helps i mean the the for the heating set
domains there are certain heuristics
that
but but i just wonder what if there's
something principled
to say yes that's actually a
good question
[Music]
so another idea i was trying with was to
recursively solve the
uh the heating set problem
with another heating set and then
recruiting yeah yeah
that's that's that's that's a very
interesting
you just have this idea of mirrors
inside mirrors
you can do it indefinitely
like okay carlos just sent to the
mips over any subset of the hard clauses
uh there are things that are done but
not really directly um
you can sort of get a course uh
identify course uh
in the beginning but not not not really
much
when it comes to the actual uh
search part no as far as i
i know so fahim you know
has some weird looking tricks in max hs
which maybe work on some specific
instance
that are maybe not as you know
something that you could really publish
on and algorithmically
maybe do yeah anything to add to that
um i mean i'm thinking of constraint
cheating so we do send
yeah yeah that's what i refer to yeah
yeah
but not say again you
i it was hard to hear so if you have a
clause
containing only blocking variables you
can just convert that
into a linear inequality and give that
to the mip solver for example
and this kind of stuff is done on a more
technical
level so so you can sort of make infer
that okay i have these assumptions
and and and okay they actually i can
quickly infer that ah okay so there's
there's an actual
you figure out that there's essentially
a clause
over just assumptions that's of course
immediately a core
in some sense
right so you can fit that and that's
done
in the beginning but i i think
still not not not really um
in other contexts we've done so if
people follow the asp talk by those
rosten
i think it was a week ago so uh i did
with a student of mine
an asp heating set optimizer and then
there so depending on your problem
domain you can do
things like use different kinds of
healthy relaxation
relaxations and their lp relaxations
when you when you have the power of
of a mip solver as well so but in max
nothing really is done okay uh so let me
continue
um so that we'll hear about the
incomplete as well
so yeah um so as i said implicit hitting
said
uh solver sorry heating set solver
provides a candidate path
and and and shots over system no no
that's not a passage
um okay so so our healing set is first
empty so
so we'll just check with the thought
solver if
s is g and that's not the case um
so we get a core stating for example
just like in the erms's example stating
that
you know we need to visit one of these
neighbors
so here's the core over qr and g
k and then
the ip solver gets this as
a as a core and there's a picks one of
these as a hitting set
say q and now
now we rule out q and ask if if
there's there's a path essentially that
goes only through q
and that's of course not the case for
example because of a and b
are not visited then you have to go
through a or b
so that's in a chord and this is a bit
of a trivial example because it turns
out that
if you do in this problem setting all of
the cars will be disjoint
and over unit clauses as well
so and this continues so now you get a
hitting set that hits one of
the cores notice that it changed it used
to be q now it's k
and then this is how what happens
so you don't really have a focus to use
or you always
compute a hitting set over the set of
course and it's independent of the
previous hitting set
over the course that you had
now you hit a and q and remove that and
then there's always this barrier that
you have to go through
and it continues
barrier barrier barrier okay
and at some point uh the eyepiece over
guesses right in terms of hitting
something optimally that
consists of a path now notice that we
have
all these cores these barriers so it can
also hit
really badly so it can hit all these
cores but in a wrong way and that
doesn't constitute the path still
so this is quite a problematic case as
well i think for an implicit heating set
solver
it has to be quite lucky um
so but yeah but when it's lucky and it
does hit
correctly and of course uh
when you're at the correct bound
you're almo you've almost solved the
problem
uh let me that's a good nice bridge to
stating that you really don't implement
the implicit headaches approach
like as the rudimentary you know
skeleton as i
as i showed you so you do all sorts of
tricks for example you do a disjoint
phase
where you don't just extract one core at
each iteration with the set soil but you
do a disjoint phase where you
extract the core and then tell the
solver disregard those clauses
is there another car disregard those
crosses are well is there another
card so you get this disjoint course
essentially bought for free because
after the first quarter that's always
calls tends to be quite trivial
uh and then you can throw all of the
course to the next
headings it type echo
then you can use tricks from the
classical ipa literature
because there's an lp solver there
so for example you get reduced costs
and and this allows you to actually
start fixing uh
values of variables to to
so it's essentially these reduced costs
tell us that
given that we have tight enough upper
and lower bounds
currently we can actually
infer that we can deem a soft clause
not to be satisfied we can just fix
the assumption variable to true in that
clause or
we can deem that okay we can fix this
assumption to false
there is an optimal solution that fixes
uh
source the the
satisfies of the softballs and this
upper and lower bound information comes
from these tricks
actually so you do this disjoint phase
and at some point the set solver says
start but that has nothing to do with an
optimal solution really
but it gives us a bound because it gives
us some solution
so it gives us an upper bound right
so you have this bounce information that
you can use in collaboration with the
ipatrix
and jeremy has last year proposed that
sat they even got the best paper award
for this abstract course that sort of
brings some elements of the corrigan
that approaches to and since it
has and binds binds sort of course
together
you know more because if you noticed in
the hitting set approach
it's sort of the ip solver it doesn't
really
you know it's it's a bit lost it can be
a bit lost and it's a good example of
how the shortest path example that shows
and these are really
anything what these abstract cores are
or this would be a separate seminar
you must do you have a sentence on that
you add extension variables to the
heating set problem
that are more expressive and can capture
cars
more expressively that's a very short
explanation but
somehow they bind bind the cores
together
better okay thanks
and
yeah so cplex yeah you can use soulplex
it doesn't affect performance much you
might see some degradation but as
softlex is quite good uh so
these are still not that hard you know
there's a lot of iterations and then
these costs are not too hard
so you won't lose much
i don't know why we and everyone else
wants to use cplex
i think there's no reason except that
it's the first thing that comes to mind
still
due to history how many iterations
aha that depends
a lot on the instance
and the other point thing to point out
is that
another question that someone typically
asks is that
uh what what's the bottleneck
and it's really interesting that it
depends on the problem as well
a lot so sometimes the sat solver is the
bottleneck the core extraction is the
bottleneck
and ah and in in any implicit hitting
set
algorithms you need to minimize the
course
or to a great extent find small cores to
sort of minimize them to a threshold and
then if you're using too much time for
the
mini minimization you should give up but
you really want
tight as tight cores as possible
but yeah sometimes the the heating set
problem gets bad
sometimes the car extraction gets bad
and then
often neither get and that's why it's
it's sort of competitive
and and the well i
i don't know who wrote this usually
superior to cplex but
uh it's interesting really to notice
that if you think about maxad
encodings or problems then then uh
when c plex is good implicitly has
a approach tends to be as well but and
then you can beat suplex with
this
all right uh yeah then
maybe jeremies can continue with the
incomplete stuff unless there's more
questions
so just a just a comment i i'm um
i have a little toy where i combine
heating sets with core guided
and i found it quite useful for finding
um near optimal solutions
you have a two phases one one where it
finds as many cores as it
can cheaply and then does hitting sets
over those and when
once it runs over out of steam does uh
core relaxation to make progress
okay so so yeah i just wonder
there must be a lot of things one can
draw in from say core enumeration
techniques to to to leverage
this hitting set world yeah i think the
the if you think about these different
current approaches putting them in the
right way
together would be the
what you would want to do the question
yeah so i think there are two things i
haven't seen one is to leverage
core enumeration and the other is
to refine upper bound so that maybe
that's your next
section but you can you can really
uh as you do this core enumeration you
find
local solutions that you can also
improve right yeah
and to really uh and that feeds back
into course so
in in in practice though so i i uh
some years ago we actually did a sort of
a max out based
implicit heating set approach for a
specific problem domain
and and if you go beyond these sort of
evaluations where you have these
heterogeneous benchmark sets and you
actually know more about your problem
and you know actually how to get really
good course
in in different ways than just using a
sat solver
and in that domain that we were working
with it's sort of causal discovery
uh the sets over a horrible course
just really huge and then there were
very small ones that you
we sort of figured out a sort of an
automatized way to figure out these
templates that you can
quickly compute the course out of uh uh
some course out of your input yeah
yeah and and and that now now sort of
the world opens up because if you start
plugging in this domain-specific
information to this
this type of an approach it really helps
so that's constraints
right you're essentially detecting some
cardinality constraints
no no no so this is really a domain
specific so this
in this this setting there's a weird
notion of paths and
and very complicated notion of paths
and inconsistencies between paths and
then and now you figure out small chords
that the sub solver never could find so
you could have
we could have chords of length three and
the set solver would give us scores of
length
40. and so without this information the
approach wouldn't work really too well
but if you know this then it does
so you have to sort of help the solver
to start and and now you start getting
better up
bounding bounce information right as
well
okay so uh yeah that means i guess you
can
continue yeah you need to just
stop sharing i'm sorry yeah there we go
all right so we're running out of time
and we as you can see
we got a lot of things to talk about so
i'll briefly go over some things in the
incomplete world and
shamelessly pick my own work to talk
about some more
uh so why would
why do we want to do incomplete solving
well the obvious answer is scalability
and the second obvious answer is that in
many practical applications we might not
care about a formal proof of optimality
if we have a good solution
it might not matter if it's not provably
the optimal one
and instead we just want to find a good
solution
as fast as possible and especially in
macset
the incomplete approaches tend to be
these so-called anytime algorithms
that find intermediate solutions this
has been hinted upon in this
here already so
as um essentially all of the different
types of algorithms that we talked about
here
effective implementations of them do
find in
non-optimal solutions during search and
if you terminate them they can give you
one of those
they might not be optim you might not
get guarantees
on on their quality but in practice
they often are quite good and this
includes the core guided and the
implicitly that based algorithms
so the central question in incomplete
solving is actually how do we combine
these different approaches
and shift their focus from trying to
prove optimality
as efficiently as possible to instead
trying to find
a solution that is as good as possible
quickly
so if we look at the solvers from last
year's max evaluation
in the incomplete track we see that
almost all of them implement more than
a single algorithm type so the deal here
is is
it's very much to take different kinds
of algorithms
and try to make as effective use of them
as possible
instead of just picking one approach and
sticking with it until you find
your optimal optimality proof or or have
to terminate
so here are the three approaches i'm
gonna
talk say something about the first is to
go back to the model improving search
and quickly show
talk a bit about why that isn't as
effective on money
as a complete approach and what you can
do to make it more effective in the
incomplete setting
and then the one i'm going to talk a bit
more about is what we call core boosted
search this is work i did with peter
stuckey and amir demirovic
uh with and it's an algorithm that
combines core guided and model improving
search in a very much
non-trivial way and finally if i have
time i'll say something about some
stochastic local search approaches
that have been proposed from access
so model improving search should in this
this we already talked about
this is just you get a solution for
example by invoking it is that solver on
your heart closes
and then you encode this cardinality
constraint that says give me another
solution that is better
and then you keep on going until this ad
solver tells you
now i can't find a solution that is
better
and why this isn't good as effective on
as a complete approach we've sort of
already touched the bond
and it's because of this encoding of the
cardinality constraints
and in a more general case the suitable
and constrained
they can get very large if you have
millions of soft boxes you end up
just choking the solver on this large
constraint
but in the incomplete setting there's
been some clever work on what you can do
to sort of make that easier
and one is the so-called varying the
resolution approach where you just
bluntly take a constant and divide all
of your weights by that constant
and just leave out weights that
with weight leave out clauses whose
weight go to zero when you divide
because you're just looking for a
solution you're not
necessarily looking for the best
possible one and you don't need to
guarantee optimality
and the second improvement is the this
the core boosted search
that i'm gonna spend most of the
remaining time on
so the intuition for to see the
intuition for core boosted search
search we go back to this grid and the
core guided approach
as i hope is clear to most of you by now
when we invoke a max at solver on this
instance we're asking for
the shortest path from sdg
but if you now remember the approach
where you relax each course separately
we can see what happens after a few
iterations
so this relaxed formula can be seen as
asking
what is the length of the shortest path
that goes from any
goes from the core one of the variables
of the core in the core a b
to one of the squares in the core q
q k or r so this is a new max at
instance that has a lower optimal cost
and there's nothing that actually says
that we have to
keep on doing this core valid approach
we can just stop
at any point and change to another
approach
this is essentially what we call car
boosted search
so we start in a core guided phase and
if you happen to find the optimal
solution we're happy
and we end if not we then take the final
reformulated instance and give that
to a model improving algorithm
and the intuition for why we would want
to do this it comes from this
bottlenecks that we've already talked
about
so for the core guided phase you don't
have to use big cardinality constraints
but the core extraction steps can be get
increasingly more difficult
and the model improving case the initial
size of the
pseudo-boolean or cardinality constraint
might be really large
so you might want to try to do anything
you can to decrease it
so by combining these two in this in
this way
we're expecting to get something that is
never significantly worse
than either one of these individual
components but actually what we found is
that this combination can even be better
than even any single
than either of its components there's a
plot showing the evolution of the
gap that means difference between the
upper and the lower bond
over time on a specific instance
the blue line up here is the linear
search component which is the model
improving algorithm
and we see that the pseudo boolean is
the weighted instance
so the pseudo boolean constraint is just
too large for the solver to make any
progress
over the five minutes that we gave it
and now the orange line here is a core
guided component
which initially is able to find some
cores and improve
improve the bound but then after after
some time
it stagnates and gets stuck in this
plateau
and then finally this combination this
core boosted surge
starts off in the core guided search
matching its performance
and then before the stagnation appear
happens it switches to the linear phase
and due to the reform reformulation
steps done during the core guided phase
the new boolean constraint is actually
small enough
for the solver to be able to make
further progress
and find easily the best solution out of
all of these three
and after publishing this work it's been
further improved by putting and
local search shot solver at the start
and this led to state-of-the-art
performance in the incomplete category
on the unweighted instances
and then for the weighted instances what
you want to do is
basically a sort of stochastic local
search approach
so as i'm sure many of you can see
the hard part for a basic for a
stochastic local surgeon
in sat is to guarantee you need to
guarantee that your heart clauses are
satisfied so if you just go around
flipping literals it's very hard to
make sure of that so
there are some proposed solutions to
this and one very natural one is to
extend the weight function that you have
to all clauses
that means the hard clauses as well you
start off by putting
some weight they use one i have to wait
for heart classes
and then you keep flipping literals and
and increasing the weights
of clauses that are frequently
unsatisfied with the hope of finding
solutions that actually
satisfy all of all of your hard poses as
well
but it turns out that a better idea is
simply to use ad solver
to make sure that you find solutions
that satisfy heart clauses
so very briefly this is the final time
we go we'll go back to the grid
you have a solution then you start
looking at all of your soft clauses
first you look at the subclause not a
you see that your current solution
falsifies it
because the path goes through a so you
ask the sat solver
for a new solution that follows all of
your all of the soft closes that you've
already assigned
plus the new one so you're saying find
me a path that does not go through a
set solver is happy to give you one for
example this one
and then you move on to your next stop
pause which is b
now in this solution the path goes
through b so you're again asking the sat
solver for a solution that does not
that satisfies the clause that means the
path that does not go through b
but also satisfies the previous clause
so
you're asking it for a path that does
not go through b
nor a and this time
cannot find one so you add the negation
of yourself pause
into the fixed clauses and
whenever you find a clause that is
already satisfied by your best solution
you
don't need that solver and you just keep
trying
and by doing this you actually end up
with a currently state-of-the-art art
approach on the in the incomplete
category for weighted distances
so this is my this is the very much
uh shortened version of the this part of
the talk we're trying to find
increase the scalability of microsoft
solvers without sacrificing the solution
quality too much
and of the off of the different
approaches that exist
we've seen that they tend to exhibit
orthogonal performance
on different domains as matthew also
said it very much depends on the problem
domain
and hence in order to be as good as
possible you want to try to combine
solvers
combine solving techniques as well as as
well as you can and
this is from the tutorial part if you
want to try your solvers this
you should go to the evaluation i'll try
to try and incomplete solver
you should go to the evaluation wave
page to see how well they did
but again if you have a new domain it's
very much possible that some other
solver is going to be the best one
for your domain so it might pay off to
try the other ones as well
so should i just wrap this up or do you
want to say something
yeah i have a question actually i guess
we already talked about this a little
bit but again
the understanding like which
algorithmically which approaches are
good for which type of problem
is there anything we can say like yeah i
mean
i don't know core guided is good for
problem
instances of type such and such and
model improving
seems to be much better for problems of
type whatever
or no there is really there isn't
there's nothing that i'm happy with
you can say stuff like if you have a low
optimal cost
then you might want to do a core guided
search which is
essentially essentially a lower bonding
church but at the same time how would
you know
if the cost is optimal then if you have
lots of diverse weights it might pay off
to try
the ihs implicitly set approaches
because then you're letting
and meep solver do the weight handling
and if you have a high optimal position
you want to could try and
model improving but beyond experimental
level
like testing and this sort of in my
opinion a bit
maybe even a bit naive statement i don't
know
it would be interesting to have a better
one and the cost of different weights
would that be
because like the encodings get expensive
or
is it also like for other reasons um
if you have a lot lots of different
weights
then a core guided approach needs the
standard trick
that might be alluded to will result in
lots of residual weights so you're going
to get a
more significant blow up in your formula
if you're doing a purely forgotten
approach and the pb construct on the
model improving side
the encodings for the pv constraints
that are commonly used the size of them
depend
on on the the more diverse you have your
weights
the larger your encoding is going to be
so and to just
blow up the formula more and more
and then there's one more question
because you you mentioned this idea of
somehow just dividing the weights
and do sort of uh if i understood like a
rough search first and then maybe
look at the actual problem when you run
there's also i think this
uh what is referred to if i'm using the
correct terminology as stratification
where you just
basically just look at the large weights
first is that
it's kind of the same or is it slightly
different or
how do they um in stratification you're
essentially
not changing the weights you're just
saying that
i'm gonna look at the this subset of
weights first
and try to find my pores and do
rotations over those
in the varying resolution that i
mentioned
you're dividing the weights in order to
also decrease
the size of the pb constraint in your
rough search so very
sort of roughly speaking the approach i
mentioned here is for
model improving search while the
stratification is for quark added search
we'll see thanks
do you have a question nikolai yeah do
you know if any of the core guided
methods backtrack over which course it
uses for relaxation or they always
fix with a relaxation i think
as far as as far as i know they don't
backtrack but that would be an
interesting question to explore
if you should and how you should in that
case because if you make a
bad decision you're basically host
yeah the problem might be that the
encode the relaxation
the process you introduce if you then
decide to backtrack you might have to
sort of
restart yourself solar yeah but
that might pay off i said i like the
idea the question is have anybody done
i mean is there any
is it
as far as i know no
uh and we had a few more slides just
summing up what we talked about there
are a number of different
approaches that you can use uh
developing an intuition for
what you want to use or a theoretical
understanding would even be even better
and an interesting future work
and then some further reading saheem
gave a talk on
similar topics just a while ago and i'm
i'm actually going to give a shorter
talk on max at pre-processing
in in the beginning of may as well so
you're all welcome to come there
i guess we're sort of out of time i'm of
course happy to answer any questions
but if there are none i'd like to thank
you all
for your attention
big thanks to both i think we usually go
over time so i'd say there's
you know people can always exit when
they like and uh
if there are any questions and if the
speakers still have energy to answer
then we're happy today yeah i mean no
hurry though so
go for it
i have a question
about this answered course i asked
before
for computing this answer course you
only consider the
i understood that you only consider this
soft classes
but might it make sense to consider also
the heart
classes i mean for the example you
presented it makes sense without
heart clauses but maybe in another
example
consider um compute the call
answer call maybe which contains also
hard clauses but then
just somehow not not consider them
discard them
i don't know what it is it was clear
well in a way sort of
now there are people who are better at
fat solvers than what
than me but but it feels to me that
by using these assumption variables and
putting them on a soft class
i don't know if it would be harder or
more complicated to compute
the sort of full onset core with the
hard process as well
compared to only computing the soft boss
part
for maxset you still have to satisfy all
of your hard passes so that's sort of
why you don't
why we don't care so to say but that's
an interesting
question you would get more info
because i was thinking maybe this um
soft classes
all together are not answered but
together with the heart clauses they
become
everything becomes answer this was my
intuition but i don't know i'm not a max
i mean
that is usually the case i mean as with
the example that we saw here
the soft courses usually encode some
kind of an objective function
so if you just take the software if you
have the path example if you just take
the soft process
the solver will just say well don't
don't visit any nodes
so you need the hard process to to sort
of get the unsatisfied
unsatisfiability so that is usually the
case you need hard houses to have
onset in many practical benchmarks
okay thank you
any other questions
i i also uh forgot to mention by put it
in the chat that
workshop simon's workshop participants
those who are registered for the simon's
workshop should have access to the
gather town
workshop room and you're welcome to to
meet there
after the seminar or i guess already now
um so i should have mentioned
another thing i could perhaps mention is
that next week we're having a talk by
bart
bogart on explainable
constraint programming i think sort of
hopefully the simon's webpage would
contain more information and i think the
week after
that on april 27th we're doing uh qbf
solving with martinez
just by you know program announcements
um anything else
we did have a lot of questions during
the seminar proper so maybe
people feel they got to ask what they
needed to ask i don't see anything in
the chat at this point if
any of the participants want to ask
anything then please
so i guess what one thing adam yeah so
like a high level question you you sort
of alluded to it a little bit
i guess that this implicit hitting set
approach
is sort of a hybrid approach in the
sense that
you're using stuff that mip solvers are
good at and then
you're using you're somehow combining
the boolean search that max
provides with the more lp kind of view
that
map solvers would provide have you
thought about or or
do you know if anyone has explored like
a tighter
say max at lp slash
integration or would that make sense
i that would that would be interesting
and
i i'm assuming you might be alluding to
your own paper
on on this no i'm not we have certainly
persuaded i don't view this as a
i'm not doing self plugs all the time so
no no but i mean
i've i've read that and it feels like
you could maybe do something similar
with that set perhaps
so i don't know of any approaches that
go beyond this reduced cost
than max what he was talking about but
i'm sure there is something to do
to do there
um yeah no but because it's somehow i
mean it's a very high level
like you basically take two black boxes
and it's a bit intriguing that you
somehow identify this part where
yeah somehow the the mid solvers are
very good at this type of problem and
then
max that's always like good at the other
uh
and it's like well yeah i i mean you
could you could like imagine like i
don't know having a max at solver and
then once in a while just solving an lp
relaxation except that
somehow i don't think when you're having
a cnf and you're relaxing i guess those
are pretty terrible relaxations i guess
this is sort of this is my thoughts when
reading these approaches i don't know
if people aren't better at healthy
revelations say they are they are i'll
take your word for it but
but that would be interesting to know if
you could gain something
i i don't claim to know what i'm talking
about at this point i'm mostly
speculating maybe
nikolai wants to say anything
maybe it's related do you run mib
solvers
on the magsat competition
set oh yeah this is yeah good good yes
there was a solver
a few years ago i can't remember exactly
but there was one
uh which sort of just worked i think it
worked
there might be something else but but in
broad terms it worked by encoding it
that's what i'm solving it
with a mip solver just just just the
classical
like direct encoding would be good to
just have a back baseline to to
so so it's well known what the
what the comparison points are yeah yeah
at some point
is it clear how skip would perform say
and then the latest competition
so some years ago it used to be that if
you run
you know you would just win
but it's not anymore like this
the cardinals are saying
but i think the the current question is
okay how does it compare to mid
and then if if the competition
evaluation basically has a vanilla
mac set encoding into mip
which which is i mean totally trivial
right
yeah can you hear me yeah
guys i don't know if you heard what i
said but it used to be their case like
you used
years ago right some years ago uh it was
the case that if you just run
you know cplex or whatever you would win
uh or
be the best in the evaluation but it's
not anymore the case
yeah but it's true that it should be
there by default
that's a very good point once you just
have it there
always as a comparison as a based one
because that's clear that it's clear
that you would need to win it
but it's of course the same if you think
about you know
if you want to incentivize people to
work on it
it's good to maybe not have it there
until you're better
come on but
i mean it is a relevant question because
like i think
if you take the i think if you take the
pseudo-boolean competition
um which doesn't happen very often i
guess latest
version was in 2016. and so
and you run skip on it even i don't know
i i guess
like european seaplax would be even
better but i think skip
that mips over skip wins the pseudo
boolean competition yeah
yeah yeah and that is of course i mean
that is depressing
yeah but for max maxwell it's not the
case i think anymore if you
if you do it i think you won't win uh
be the best but but yeah for pb i think
because it's pretty much
mid then already so it's sort of in the
ballpark of
meep solvers another thing is of course
that
what what what where are the
where are the benchmark like the problem
domains that are
uh clearly pbo that and how how
do they differentiate from mip uh in
general
yeah that's good to an extent that that
you know the classical
engine cut doesn't just kill the
competition
well so i mean it's not the case in
general i think it's a benchmark
selection problem also for instance i
mean we've seen that
i think if you want to analyze say like
binarized neural
networks then i think it seems to be
somewhat
conventional-ish wisdom that map solvers
are
not so good because they somehow when
you relax these
like what whatever they're called these
relu constraints activation constraints
they're like
not good for lp relaxation also i think
we've seen that that
um this is say like hardware circuit
verification problems
map doesn't seem terribly good
whereas pb pseudo boolean solvers can be
really good and also suitable solvers
can be really good for banners neural
networks and i guess
mac sat solvers have been used for like
this robust or adversarial learning and
stuff
yeah yeah i guess it's a matter of how
logical the
somehow how good is it easy to reason
over the
actual problem right but also victor so
there's a
very good point i think by victor miller
made in the chat that is worth pointing
out that
one reason for the superiority of of
skip or at least of think of cplex and
grobby
is that their pre-processing works hard
to recognize and exploit substructures
and i think also like
really to decide things like oh
it seems like you're you're doing a
knapsack problem well i'll pull out my
dedicated dynamic programming algorithm
to just try to solve this problem i mean
there are
massive amounts of of like domain
knowledge
in these yeah it's it's very interesting
because if you run it on on the on
instances that seem very similar on the
same dome from the same domain
you see that it chooses different lp
solvers
and stuff like that as well yeah but uh
okay can you hear me yeah we can hear
you well carlos
yeah but for that uh maybe you need to
pass
more har closes to the sibling solver
if you want the simplex solvers to
recognize those structures
because otherwise you are just having
the checking function okay for the
heating set
what you are doing but you need the
higher closest or some part of the car
closes
for example what is very important is
the detection of clicks
so click click detection is very
important for max at solvers
as you know in the competition for
complete max ad solvers there is a phase
of click detection of almost one's
constraints
and this is a trick that works very well
this is why i was asking what happens if
you plug
something that is not simplex or kudobi
that we know there is some black card
going on there okay and you yes they can
open source bib solvers that maybe they
are they are not applying so much
preprocessing
this is an interesting question but i
agree with you that it would be very
nice
to have this comparison uh with siblings
cypress and gulabi
just the direct translation and to see
what happens i don't think
this is bad for the community i think
this is it should be
encouraging for us okay no no so
um so my my point was that it used to be
the case
that they win but they don't anymore i'm
just saying that
that in reality if you organize the pbo
competition for example
and and the reality is that that
currently
you know siplex or gurobi will just blow
everything out of
out of the water so it's not very
you know yeah
you know it's good to have it there but
you know you need to support people
you know of course you have to face
reality but but
but you don't get improvement with diff
different kinds of algorithmic
approaches if you don't encourage them
a couple of questions to their comments
on that so
so pre-processing their papers in max
set about pre-processing as well
right so i think the the cardinality
detection
is is one of the pre-processing steps i
i added
after looking at some flight crew
examples
it couldn't do the crew examples without
this
at most two detection um
because i mean otherwise you you kill
the core extraction and
and then there are other approaches that
look at
how you split max add constraints into
disjoint sets
if the weights are stratified right so
so there i think there are lots of room
one can do in the max ad world for just
pre-processing
for the for the detection uh
one there is some cases where the
problem is
and this is related to what you were
commenting um
before about the tracking okay
to the previous score so the problem is
the order
of the course that you retrieve because
if you do it in the correct order
just by using the ol algorithm
you are going to get the same as doing
the detection of the clicks
for some problems this is the case and
this is very important and he's telling
you that the order
is actually a key piece of the whole
story
[Music]
okay
so let's see i'm trying to
manage the chat so so kieran mccree is
apparently running off for dinner but
mentions that instances from problems
involving matching under preferences
might be another good source of
candidates for mac sat and pseudo
boolean solvers
i'm currently grading two masters
dissertations on these kind of problems
where
constraint programming is stomping over
mip and the cp encoding is very sat
friendly
except for the objective function and i
think we've also
had some news from glasgow i think the
glasgow well i don't know if i
dare to say this in nikolai's presence
so but apparently the glasgow people did
try
the pseudo-boolean solver on on these
problems also and it's killing them
absorbers
um so and kieran suggests plugging a
seminar on this
which i'm doing now namely on this is
not a simon seminar this is a 2 p.m
central european time so maybe not very
west coast friendly but still
a seminar by william petterson at the
university of glasgow talking about
these kind of problems where
where actually mip solvers seem to be
fairly soundly beaten by other
techniques
i think i was interrupting someone
though maybe or was i
oh ah i didn't i plugged this in the
wrong wait let me
let me see didn't i post this no wrong
one
oh maybe yep
kidney
and i guess nikolai you're saying and as
a smt solver right there i'm very happy
with advances in maxset and pb so you're
just an smt solver you harness anything
you can use
is that yes
i don't complain
yeah i think this is um any uh final
questions or comments which maybe we
should let our
speakers off the hook i think this is a
great discussion but uh
i guess they deserve a break at some
point
no thanks for all the good questions
good ideas
so i think that on behalf of of
everybody i'll just thank you so much
for uh
for a wonderful tutorial um
this was great um thanks
and looking forward to see you all of
you then
you know you know week from now about
explainable constraint programming
so thanks so much for today
thank you
thank you
you